hey everyone welcome to this short video
on angular in this video we will learn
about what's new with the new angular 13
version i'm sure you're aware that
angular rolled out their new version
that is angular 13 on november 3rd 2021
this video brings you all the updates
you need to know but before we begin if
you haven't subscribed to our channel
already make sure you hit that subscribe
button and bell icon to never miss an
update so let's dive in before
understanding what's new let's have a
quick look at what is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written in typescript google
maintains it and its primary purpose is
to develop single page applications as a
framework angular has clear advantages
while also providing a standard
structure for developers on a team to
work with
it enables users to develop large
applications in a maintainable manner
angular has released several versions
over the past few years with every
release it has seen significant
improvements making it a popular choice
amongst developers today so let's look
at what's new with angular 13.
so the first one is it's completely iby
followed by that we have a new update
that is api component update
next we have modifications in the
angular package format followed by that
we have bye bye to internet explorer
next is the framework modifications and
dependency updates next we have improved
testing and debugging
followed by that we have some
performance improvements and finally we
have improvements in angular cli
now let's look at each one of them in
detail the first one it's completely ivy
the view engine is no longer available
with the angular 13 update and the
framework is now 100 percent ivy
these will help to speed up the
compilation and boost platform
efficiency for your projects
next the api component update before the
changes in angular version 13
dynamically creating components required
a lot of boilerplate code the new api
removes the need for component factory
resolver being injected into the
constructor
iv creates the opportunity to
instantiate the component with view
container ref dot create component
without creating an associated factory
followed by that we have the
modifications in the angular package
format the angular package format apf
has been streamlined and modernized to
better serve developers to streamline
the apf10 version 13 the team removed
older output formats including view
engine specific metadata to modernize it
they have standardized on more modern
javascript formats such as es2020
libraries built with the latest version
of the apf will no longer require the
use of ngcc as a result of these changes
library developers can expect leaner
package outputs and faster execution
now the fourth update bye bye to
internet explorer 11. removing ie 11
support allows angular to leverage
modern browser features such as css
variables and web animations via native
web apis what's more the apps will be
smaller and load faster because we can
remove ie specific polyfills and code
paths
it also removes the need for
differential loading developers will
benefit from improved apis and well
infrastructure while application users
will benefit from faster loading and an
improved user experience
now the fifth update
framework modifications and dependency
updates
angular version 13 also features some
helpful updates and important changes
first up rxjs 7.4 is the default for
apps created with ng new existing apps
using rxjs version 6 will have to
manually update using the npm install
rxjs at 7.4 command
now let's look at the sixth update
improve testing and debugging
there are important improvements to
testbet that now do a better job of
tearing down test modules and
environments after each test the dom is
now cleaned after every test and
developers can expect faster less memory
intensive less independent and more
optimized tests
now let's jump into the seventh update
that is the performance improvements
these recent updates in angular 13 have
undoubtedly resulted in major
improvements by introducing unusual
modifications such as the opt-in feature
is enabled by default global scripts and
bundles have been optimized in union
type templates auto completion is
supported
now let's look at the final update that
is improvements in the angular command
line interface
angular now supports the use of
persistent build cache by default for
new version 13 projects the valuable
feedback from rfc persistent built cache
by default led to this tooling update
that results in up to 68 improvement in
build speed and more ergonomic options
and so with that we have come to an end
of this short video on angular 13. i
hope this video helped you if you have
any questions let us know in the
comments thank you so much for being
here and watch out for more videos from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here